People keep asking scientists, when are we
going to clone a mammoth?
Look.
We'll get there when we get there.
It's not the easiest thing in the world!
Hello to all you living beings out there,
I'm Trace and you're watching DNews -- Extinction
happens.
But it can really suck when an entire species
just dies out.
Then again, so can bringing back extinct things
ah-la, Jurassic Park...
If you haven't seen Jurassic Park // WHAT?
Go watch it!
It's a CLASSIC.
// cloning is used to bring dinosaurs back
from the dead.
Now, 20 years later, the technology is catching
up to the science fiction.
We can CLONE EXTINCT THINGS!
And in the Internet Age, the Woolly Mammoth
seems to be the popular choice...
The mammoth became extinct 4,000 years ago,
but a 20-to-60-thousand-year-old tusk was
found in a construction pit in Seattle on
Valentine's Day!
Due to its similarity to elephants, some scientists
think we can use DNA from found parts to bring
these bad boys back to life.
Though they sequenced the genome of the woolly
mammoth back in 2008.
but do you see any wandering around?
Nope.
Because knowing the DNA structure isn't enough.
Repairing a damaged mammoth DNA strand using
elephant DNA would be excruciatingly slow
and it's pretty near impossible to tuck all
six feet of it into a microscopic cell nucleus.
Last year, a preserved mammoth carcass was
discovered in Siberia -- frozen in the ice.
While digging it out, a mis-aimed ice pick
nicked its skin and blood flowed out!
So now scientists are looking for an in-tact
DNA-packed nucleus of one of those red blood
cells.
If they get one then BINGO.
MAMMOTH DNA.
Then could use the same method used to clone
Dolly the sheep -- called somatic cell nuclear
transfer.
Basically, they replace the nucleus in an
egg cell of a related animal with the nucleus
of the animal to be cloned.
If it takes, scientists implant the mammoth
embry into a surrogate mother -- likely an
African Elephant.
Next stop de-extinction!
Though it all sounds relatively easy, it ain't.
There are a handful of teams working on cloning
extinct species, including mammoths, but so
far there's no luck.
Nature has a tough time preserving DNA and
nuclei for science.
Until we find one, we'll just have to keep
watching Jurassic Park.